PROFESSOR: We spoke
about the hydrogen atom.
And in the hydrogen
atom, we drew
the spectrum, so the table, the
data of spectrum of a quantum
system.
So this is a question that I
you in general to be aware of.
What do we mean by a
diagram of the energy
levels in a central potential?
So this is something we
did for the hydrogen atom.
But in general, the diagram
of energy eigenstates
in a central potential
looks like this.
You put the energies here.
And they could be bound states
that have negative energy.
They could be even bound
states with positive energy,
depending on the system
you're discussing.
You remember the
harmonic oscillator,
the potential is naturally
defined to be positive.
And all these energy states
that the harmonic oscillator
has represent bound states.
They are normalizeable
wave functions.
In fact, you don't
have scattering states
because the potential
just reaches forever.
So in general, for
a central potential,
however, the system
is shown like that.
And we plot here l.
But l is not a
continuous variable,
so we'll put l equals 0
here, l equals 1, l equals 2,
l equals 3.
And then you start
plotting the energy levels.
You solve the radial equation.
Remember, the radial equation
is a Schrodinger equation,
minus h squared over 2m, d
second u d r squared, plus V
effective of r u equals Eu.
And V effective
of r is the V of r
that your system had, plus
a contribution from angular
momentum, 2m.
So this radial equation is a
collection of radial equations.
We've tried to emphasize
that many times already.
And you solve it
first for l equal 0,
then for l equal 1, for l
equal 2, you go on and on.
So you solve it for l equal 0.
And just like as in any
one-dimensional problem,
for l equals 0, you
solve this equation
and you find energy levels.
So you sketch them like that.
Those are the energy
levels for l equals 0.
This is the ground state of
the l equal 0 radial equation.
Now just to remind you,
this is the hard part
of solving the
Schrodinger equation.
Because at the end
of the day, the psi
is u of r over r times some Ylm.
So the l that you have
here, the term is a Y
and the m is arbitrary.
In fact, the u doesn't
know about the m value.
So here you have
these energy levels.
And then what happened with
this hydrogen atom is you keep
solving, of course,
for all the l's.
And in general, when you
solve for l equals 1,
you may find some
levels like this.
It's a miracle when
the levels coincide.
There's no reason why
they should coincide.
They happen to coincide
for the hydrogen atom.
And that's because of a very
special symmetry of the 1 over
r potential orbit.
Then for l equal
2, you solve it.
And for l equal 3, you solve.
And you find these
states, and that's
the diagram of states
of a central potential.
For the hydrogen
atom, of course,
first, all the
energies were negative
and the energy levels coincide.
So this is the ground state of
the l equal 0 radial equation.
This is the ground state of
the l equal 1 radial equation.
the l equal 2 radial equation.
This is the ground state
of the whole system.
So this is what we call
plotting the spectrum
in a radial potential problem.
And it's a generic form.
So we were doing this
for the hydrogen atom
last time to try to
understand the various orbits.
And we had for the
hydrogen atom, V of r
was a potential like this,
minus e squared over r.
And then you have sometimes
the l contribution
that this function diverges
towards the origin, 1
over r squared.
And by the time you
add them together,
This is the original
potential, so this could
be thought as l equals 0 case.
Then if you have some l
over here and some other l,
maybe like that, these
are the various potentials
that you get.
And in general, you
may want to figure out,
for example, if
you have an energy
level, some particular energy,
what are the turning points.
So let's consider for
that case that's just one
curve that we care about.
And the electron will be going
from some value of the radius,
so this is the plot of
the effective potential
of the function of radius.
And we'll go from
one to another.
They could be called
r minus to r plus.
And our semi-classical
interpretation,
which is roughly good if you're
talking about high quantum
numbers, high principle
quantum numbers, high l
quantum numbers, is
that you have an ellipse
and the radial distance
to the center where
the proton is located goes
from r plus to r minus.
The electron is
bouncing back and forth.
That is the classical picture.
In the quantum
mechanical picture,
you expect something
somewhat similar.
There's going to be a wave
function, maybe a wave
function here, psi squared.
And it's going to be vanishingly
small before this point.
And then by the
time you get here,
it's going to be very
fast, and then decay again.
So the probability
distribution will
mimic the time spent
by the particles,
as we used to argue before.
So let's do a little exercise of
calculating the turning points.
So how do we do that?
Well, we set h squared l times
l plus 1 over 2mr squared,
minus e squared over r--
that's the effective potential--
equal to the energy of some
level n, principle quantum
number n.
So it would be minus e squared
over 2a0, 1 over n squared.
That's the value
of the energy En.
And the solutions of
this quadratic equation
are going to give us the r plus
and the r minus of the orbit.
So it's probably worthwhile
to do a little transformation
and to say r equal a0 times
x, where x is unit free.
And then the equation becomes
h squared, l times l plus 1,
over 2ma0 squared,
times l times l plus 1,
over x squared, minus e squared
over a0x, is equal to minus
e squared over 2a0,
1 over n squared.
So the unit should work out.
We should get a nice
equation without units.
So what must be happening
is that the coefficient
in front of here, h
squared 2ma0 squared,
let's take the other a0 and
separate it out, and transform
this.
Remember, a0 was h
squared over m e squared.
So here we get h
squared over 2ma0.
And that a0 now
has an h squared.
And there's m e squared.
So the h squared
cancels, the m cancels.
And this is e squared over 2a0.
So this whole
coefficient is e squared
over 2a0, which is nice because
now the e squared over a0,
the e squared over a0, a
squared over a0, cancel.
And we get l times l
plus 1 over x squared--
I've canceled all this factor--
minus 2 over x is equal
to minus 1 over n squared.
So I multiplied by the
inverse of this quantity.
It clears up the factor
in the first term.
It produces an extra factor
of 2 in the second term.
And you've got a nice
simple quadratic equation.
AUDIENCE: Question?
PROFESSOR: Yes?
AUDIENCE: Where do you get
the extra [INAUDIBLE] l,
l plus 1 [? come from? ?]
PROFESSOR: Oh,
there's no such thing.
There's too many of them.
Thank you very much.
Yes, too many, 1 over x squared.
Thank you.
So let's move this
to the other side--
plus 1 over n squared equals 0.
So this is the main equation.
And we can write this--
well, the solution for 1 over
x is a quadratic equation in 1
over x.
So I'll write it here.
1 plus/minus square root of
1 minus l times l plus 1,
over n squared, divided
by l times l plus 1.
That's just from the
quadratic formula.
So then you invert it.
So x is now l times l plus 1,
over 1 plus/minus square root
of 1 minus l, l plus
1 over n squared.
And we multiply by
the opposite factor
to clear the square root.
So 1 minus/plus square root of
1 minus l times l plus 1 over n
squared.
And the same factor here--
1 minus/plus square
root of 1 minus l,
l plus 1 over n squared,
all of these things.
But that's not so bad.
You get l times l plus
1, times this factor
that you had in the numerator--
that still is the same--
1 minus l, l plus
1 over n squared.
Now we're after an interesting
piece of information, the two
sizes of the ellipse, so it's
worth simplifying what you got.
This equation is not nice
enough, so we're simplifying.
And in the denominator, you
have a plus b times a minus b.
So it's 1 minus 1 minus l,
l plus 1, over n squared.
And the good thing is that the
denominator, the 1 cancels.
And you get the plus,
l times l plus 1 over n
squared, that cancels, that one.
So that, at the end of the day,
we get a pretty nice formula.
The formula is x is
equal to n squared,
1 minus/plus, 1 minus l times
l plus 1, over n squared,
like that.
So if we wish, it's r plus/minus
is x multiplied by a0,
so it's n squared a0, 1
minus/plus square root
of 1 minus l times l
plus 1, over n squared.
OK, so the ellipse is
defined by those two values
that we have here.
But the surprising
thing is that the sum
over the ellipse,
and its eccentricity,
is dramatically affected
by the values of l.
In fact, for l equals largest,
l will be comparable to n.
Remember, l can go
up to n minus 1.
So at that point,
this is essentially 1.
You cancel this and
there's nothing here.
So r plus and r minus become
about the same for l equals n
minus 1. r plus is almost
the same as r minus
And the orbit is circular,
completely circular.
On the other hand,
for l equals 0,
the orbit is completely
elliptical in that the radius
for l equal 0, this
is 0, 1, plus/minus 1.
So sometimes it's twice this
value, sometimes it's 0.
So you have the case
where r minus can be 0,
and you have just an orbit
that is like that, r minus 0,
so extremely elliptical--
elliptical.
Of course, that is the
semi-classical approximation.
So it's more reliable when
you have a reasonable l.
And finally we can
say here, for example,
one interesting thing, that
r plus plus r minus, over 2,
which is this--
r plus plus r minus
is the total longest
axis of the ellipse, divided by
2, the center of the ellipse,
not the focus, that distance
is independent of l,
so you have n squared a0.
So a typical Rydberg atom
will have n equal 100.
So this is an example--
n equal 100, l equals 60, in
which case, for n equal 100,
r plus/minus is equal to
10,000a0, n squared a0,
times this factor, which in one
case is 1.8 and in the other
case is 0.2.
That's what you get for l
equal 60 and n equal 100.
So this orbit, you have
r plus about 18,000a0,
and r minus about 2,000a0.
And all of our orbits
satisfy this property
that if you have this,
r minus and r plus,
all of the orbits
with different l
have the same r
plus plus r minus.
So if this is the total
length of the major axis when
the orbit becomes
circular, it's the same.
And this distance, when the
orbit becomes very elliptical,
is the same as well.
I mentioned last time that this
nice property is degeneracy.
We're here, if you're keeping
n fixed but changing l,
you're going from
all these ellipses.
This is for l equals n minus 1.
And this one is for l equals 0.
And all this ellipses arc here.
And those are all the
semi-classical picture
of those degenerate states in
the diagram of the hydrogen
atom.
The diagram of the hydrogen
atom was something like this.
And you're looking at
all the degenerate states
that you have there.
And they are degenerate,
and you would say, well,
why are ellipses that
look like that degenerate.
Well, even Kepler apparently
knew that in Kepler's laws.
That he observed that the
period of motion of an orbit
just depended on
the semi-major axis.
So periods are
related to energies.
And it's reasonable
that we have this thing
in quantum mechanics.
Now this degeneracy, I
want to just finish up
by emphasizing
what you have here.
When somebody asks what is the
number of states you have here,
well, you have to be precise
in what you're counting.
The number of full physical
states of the quantum system
is one here, one here, one here.
But each one of this
corresponds to l equals 1,
so each one of this
is triply degenerate,
because m can be
minus 1, 0, and 1.
So here-- three states,
three states, three states.
Here-- this is five states,
five states, five states,
because they all have l equal 2.
And l equal 2 goes m
from minus 2 to plus 2.
So we don't actually
put three things here.
I think that would be confusing.
We could not put five
and we cannot see.
But it should be
remembered that there's
the implicit extra
degeneracy here
associated with the
azimuthal quantum number
that we sometimes just don't
represent it in a figure.